Welcome to talks at Google.
I'm Shane Peltzman and today we welcome
the cast Bohemian rhapsody Gwilym Lee
Rommy Malick and Joe Mozilla
[inaudible].
Hello Buddy.
How's it going?
Yeah. Um, cool. So, uh,
congratulations guys on awesome film.
I saw the from yesterday and loved it.
A lot of the people here,
I think what we're able to see it last
night at the screening. Did you really?
Oh yeah. Oh, I am Mike.
Uh, we happen women screened at
many times, so this is one of them,
one of the first audiences in America and
for that matter the world to see this,
which is really cool. Thank you guys for
watching. Yeah, it was, it was fantastic.
And what I actually just heard was
that, uh, and tell me if I'm wrong,
but day one of shooting,
you guys were thrown into Wembley
and shooting the live aid concert.
Is that right? Yeah, I mean,
no, no. Wembley is specifically,
it doesn't actually exist
in its old shape anymore.
So it was actually a replica full size
replica in an air field in the north of
London.
Not particularly glamorous,
but it was a pretty full way
to start a film near Luton,
near Luton metropolis.
It's a really lovely spot.
The trip have you go back in the,
in the UK. But yeah, it was a,
it was a pretty fun way to
start. Um, pretty terrifying.
But it was great because you know, you,
you sink or swim in that situation, right?
You've just got to, you've
got to go for it. Yeah.
Take your time and be cautious about it.
It just jump on in and hope for the best.
Really.
The first seven weeks were dedicated to
live aid because we were brought in six
weeks early to do band rehearsals and
to learn this 20 minutes set that we had
to get down in its entirety.
Um, and it was very precise.
It was actually for this one
concert because the actual
footage is so famous and
everyone can see it. Um, we wanted
to make sure that we were exact.
So if like John's head turned
to the left at an exact moment,
I had to do it at that moment. And, you
know, especially for Rami, he had to,
you know,
Freddie is just going nuts.
He had to have all of that down. And
so that's why we, uh, but it was great.
It was great way to bond. It was a great
way to come together as a band. Um,
Polly bander movement coach, uh, she was
instrumental in, in, you know, our morale
and are coming together and our movements.
So he was really amazing. There's,
there's, uh, uh,
his hammer to fall where Freddy's really
feeling himself and he's doing some
things with his body that I just can,
you could never
replicate.
And when you lose a shot that on the
third day we would go song by song.
Monday we did Bohemian rhapsody,
Tuesday Radio Gaga,
Wednesday we did have an
AFOL so on and so forth.
And so we would jump into the middle of
a song and I had been rehearsing this
over and over and there were twists
and things I knew I could do,
but I wasn't able to do them.
Uh, on Wednesday, on Friday,
I could do them because that's when
we ran the entire concert together.
And he realized, Oh shit, he's
riding off of pure adrenaline.
And once that adrenaline kicks in,
you're superman and damn
does that feel good?
Cause acting's a pretty great high in
and of itself being out there and uh,
having the hype of that rock star moment,
it's on another level,
the adrenaline adrenaline coursing
through your body and it's,
it's like a drug. You realize what
they all want to go out afterwards,
not let the night of her end. It was
sort of funny, too sweet. Like, you know,
when we were doing this band rehearsals,
um,
Polly would have us do all
these like sort of theater.
He exercises that maybe felt a little
silly or a little foolish like we had to
touch in before we would
start stuff or whatever.
But then when we got to that moment
where it's literally the first shot is us
coming out onto that stage,
we were all like obsessively been
like no touch and touch them.
We've got to do all the things we started.
So it was funny how like it
translated and suddenly we needed,
we needed that feeling of the energy
coming together before going out on that
stage and feeling like we can, you know,
live up to what we were rehearsing.
Freddie had some outrageous
moves as well in that,
in that concert that happens
forbit theirs, it's a PG 13,
so we couldn't actually include
this move and film, but as a,
there's a bit where in front of 70,000
people, he takes his microphone standard,
essentially just jokes off.
And it's like the brazen confidence
of the man to do that in that moment.
It was just sums him up beautifully.
And then,
and then immediately
afterwards he just turns on,
shows his ass to the entire crowd.
Only Freddy can get away with that
just now.
Just
really a movement coach Paulie, she'd
be like, all right, five, six, seven,
eight and you to twist, twist. Um,
I dosey doe wink, wink, wink,
given the [inaudible] excuse me.
It was like, look at him. He's
performing a sexual act. He's done.
You just gave you his thing.
And now he turns around and says my turn.
Um, yeah. Wanted to ask
about [inaudible]. I know,
I know it's crazy to say this,
but only Freddy could get away with that.
Unfortunately,
we didn't,
you guys didn't have the benefit of
having Freddy around to, you know,
to use it as a source for
information. And, uh, I know
Brian May was a producer on the
film, Roger Taylor and two beach. Um,
how involved were they, uh, in
terms of the films creation,
but also working with you guys directly
and, you know, how much did you,
were you able to take from them and
their experiences? They were amazing,
so generous with their
time. Um, you know, they,
they shared stories with us and, and
uh, memories and things, but, um,
but equally they were quite
adamant that we should, uh,
tell the story a warts and all.
And so they often came on set during
the live performance sequences cause I
think that's their music
producers on the film.
So that's where they felt their
expertise as most useful. Uh,
but when it came to doing the
more intimate acted scenes,
I suppose the dramatic scenes that they
left us to our own devices to give us
space to explore that
properly. Um, but yeah,
I mean from my point of view, having,
being able to meet the man died,
playing to be able to spend time with
him intimately to get to know him is just
the best. I mean, it sounds crass
to call it research, but you know,
you to spend time with someone
as a human being as an equal,
you really absorb something of their,
of their soul I think.
So that was the greatest opportunity
of all, I think for me. What,
what was one of the notes that Brian
May gave you on a limeade? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. So, so live aid, like we say, it was
the one moment being such an iconic gig.
It was the one,
the one part of the film that we really
wanted to capture in absolute detail. So,
so we rehearsed for ages to
get this right. And, um, he,
Brian was on set when we did the
first rehearsal onset and source.
Do a run through. And, uh, he came up
to me afterwards and he was like, yes,
it was very good, very good, very
accurate if you've got that down,
but just don't forget all a Rockstar
[inaudible]
it comes a certain amount of ego.
I was a really good note because what
I understood that to me and it's like,
you know,
we can,
we can mimic things in absolute
detail as much as we want vocally,
physically and all that kind of stuff.
But ultimately we've got to fill that
with our own sense of adrenaline and our
own sense of kind of energy and
joy and all that kind of thing.
So it was a really useful thing to hear
early on and to take with us throughout
the film.
Yeah. I also wanted to ask, um,
not only obviously the members of
Queen and then the manager, but I'm,
Mike Myers has a very unique
role in queens history,
especially with generations that came up.
Uh, you know, after Freddy's death, um,
and Mike Myers was cameo in the film.
I wondered what it was like to meet Mike
Meyers in that context and talk to him
about his, his role in
Queens, kind of rock history.
Did you guys know it was Mike
Meyers in the foam? The Ray Foster,
the record were record executive.
That's Mike Myers. So my neighbor,
you know when he's talking about,
uh,
no one ever banging
their heads too rhapsody,
it's never going to work. No one
will ever bang their heads. Yeah,
he showed up like that too.
He showed up in character
fully in character and to
the pain, the fear, the week,
the whole thing. And so we also
had that same double take rook
and it was just, man, I'm working
with. That was awesome because there's,
there's like a line in the script,
it's not in the movie where he just
literally says, how is Japan? Right.
That's not funny.
Just how is Japan?
And when he delivered it
and we were all like crying,
there's like five months we were all going
to each other. So I'll just jump back,
just figure it out. It's just like, but
so it was the mix of like this like,
I dunno, this innate sense of comedy,
but at the same time he cared.
So like you can come on and do like a
little cameo in something and be like,
okay,
whatever paycheck at me out of here.
He cared so deeply about
getting it perfect.
He was such a pro, he ev every word
that he said he wanted it to be. Right.
And just to see that level
of professionalism and
care that he took with it,
it was one of the first things we
shot. It made us kind of go, well,
we definitely have to at least match that.
Yeah. And so it was, it was
awesome. Awesome for it with them.
It was one of the most enjoyable days,
a few days at work that the,
there's a bit at the end, uh, of uh,
one of his scenes where Freddy throws
a rock through the window and then, uh,
he goes to see who's throwing this walk
rock and sees us kind of giving them the
finger from dumb down below.
And we were filming this in a quite
well heeled part of north London,
not too far from where I live.
Like I've got a lot of friends in the
area and it turned into just this like
hurling abuse each other and
the camera's just kept rolling.
There was nothing scripted.
So it's just Mike Myers leaning out
of a window just being so abusive.
So horrific
to the point where like there
were some people in the street,
there was a mother and her child
just like shepherding her child away.
Don't miss to this horrible man.
But honestly like, you know,
sat behind the camera for an eyeline
for Mike Myers, just like giggling,
like Giddy with excitement that
we're in this moment with this. I, I,
he's a legend in my eyes. I've
always loved him. So yeah,
the opportunity to be working
with him was awesome. Yeah,
it was this room do bluebird calling
each other twice and where anchor and you
know, I have one point I go, you know,
to shove this up your ass. And he goes,
I want a meal,
not a snack.
And it's like,
you know,
you know on SNL when you watch everybody
break and you think, is that real?
Is it game with him? It's,
we're breaking the whole time.
It's a, sorry. So, so sorry.
So sorry. Um, yeah, it was
interesting Bohemian rhapsody. I
actually went back to number two on
the charts after Wayne's world. Um,
and I wouldn't be surprised if for some
where things happen happens after this
phone is released.
I'm going to be cause
working with the, I just wanted
to hear more about, I guess your,
your guys' experience,
um,
how you came to queen and what it
was like coming into this film.
It was honoring these rock stars
because I think some bio pics, um,
can make it kind of cheesy,
the history and kind of superfluous.
And I think this film did a really good
job of honoring the music in a really
beautiful way.
Um,
uh, what it was like for like our first
experience with queen like a, yeah, yeah.
For that. Yeah. It sort of feel,
I mean like sort of growing up in the 90s
it was like listening to a lot of like
nirvana and Pearl Jam and like,
you know,
music serious and queen.
It's like so much fun and so
boisterous and like sort of crazy.
Like as a youth I felt like, oh it's
just like a gimmick or something or like,
you know, whatever. That's not my
kind of music mine, Mine's real.
They don't understand the struggle.
And then sort of like as I got older,
like into college I think is when I
really liked started listening to the,
to what they were really doing and
started seeing their genius and started
seeing how they cross all
these Sharas and they,
their music is timeless and it just spans
decades for a reason and it's just so
intricate and,
and like,
and I think that sort of my love of
queen has just gone like this throw in my
life to the point where now like it's
off the charts because like learning how
to play the songs,
you get a deeper appreciation for it.
Learning why they were written,
learning how they collaborated.
It's so insane.
But like once we were done shooting,
like I went on a road trip and all I
listened to was queen. Like I was like,
what didn't we cover?
I want to know those now too.
And it's sort of wild how like we
didn't get sick of it and just be
the more the risk is cause
cause the music is so universal.
You hear everywhere on the
radio, TV, sports, stadiums.
Every time you go and see
a game, um, you kind of,
there's a risk of taking
it all for granted and use
it. Oh yeah, there's queen.
Okay cool.
But actually to really sit
down and consider what it
must've been like to write
a song like beaming rhapsody, which
is like, you know, it was so unique,
so revolutionary at the time to think
what imagination it took to come up with a
song like that is a, is
quite something. Um, and,
and you'd see that with all of
the songs and fill cause it's a,
it's an origins foam in that sense.
You see the origins and making of all
these songs, which we do take for granted.
It's so Bohemian rhapsody, when you look
at the tape that they recorded it, it's,
it's clear that's how many
overdubs they put on it.
And at the risk of losing the entire song,
they kept going and kept going.
And if you go too far,
the whole thing will be raised.
But they just kept pushing the
limits. And, and in this movie,
the coolest thing is, you know,
we have archival, uh, you know,
obviously footage, but the art department
can show you stuff that you know,
that has a, you know, the original lyrics
on it and just just says Freddy's thing.
And the band members
just kept going. All right, we're
back to Freddy's thing today.
Galileo's again and whatnot. W w what
are we going to call it? Who knows?
It's Freddy's thing and its
insights to that. Making a,
all these songs. It's fascinating.
And this is one band where,
uh, you know, all four
members write song. Uh,
it's rare when that happens that the level
of collaboration that existed and you
know, some of the songs,
it's like you said,
they're iconic and they feel
poppy at times, you know,
the very universal, but some of the
messages in, in these songs, I mean,
you can even look at the three stages
of man and we will rock you. And, uh,
you know,
Brian May walked us through how is the
writing process on that at Abbey road
studios before we shot kind
of mind blowing moment for us.
But the guy is such a deep thinker.
He's, he's Dr. Ryan May, uh,
an astrophysicist and you know,
he's a song called 39 that if you listen,
you'd think it was a folk song.
But if you dig deep into it,
it's about time travel and it will,
it's a very,
very complex thing.
I had to,
I had to listen to it about five
times before I was like, oh, no way.
Uh,
all of the songs do that. I
mean Radio Gaga, you know,
I sit alone and watch your,
how does that I,
the lyrics go I guess at two
teenage nights.
Yes.
But it
wasn't an angel. Just one
more question, but if I'm,
we're going to take audience questions
as well. So if everyone wants the lineup,
Kevin, over your eyes, a mic and you
guys can get going right over here.
Don't be bashful. Get in line.
Um, I also wanted to ask, uh,
you kind of mentioned like you had this
fear like maybe I'll get sick of queen
songs and of course like the
opposite in fact happened. Um,
you guys were in such tight quarters
filming all these scenes together,
so many locations.
You guys essentially became a band.
And now not only during the
process of filming the movie,
but now you're a press junket.
You guys are literally touring together.
So I wanted to ask you what that
experience has been like. Honestly,
can't stand the sight of these guys.
I'm just so sick of, no, no, no.
We became like a family.
We already did.
Like it was such an important part of
the story that we wanted to capture as
like that rapport that they had, that
queen referred to themselves as a family.
It's because of the mother,
the mother ship. And uh,
so it was really important for us
to catch that. And we just, part of,
part of that was six weeks of rehearsals
before we started filming and did like
doing this live aid sequence and just
spending every hour of every day with each
other and you know, where possible while
we were playing to backing tracks, uh,
on set when it came to the filming,
we try and plug in when we could and,
and like play together as a band to,
to have to know what it's like
to have to listen to each other,
tap to keep time and all that
kind of thing. And you know, we,
we went out and hung out purely as a
matter of research and development.
Okay.
Um,
we went on vacation together
when we were done filming. Yeah.
That's what happened. Like when we
went to Scotland and then to Paris,
like it was just like we
didn't want it to end.
Um, and that's, I think kind of,
I've never done that before. Yeah.
We all came together since.
Okay.
It'll pay the other day,
two days ago in Miami.
Yeah. Yeah. This is
the craziest thing. Um,
I don't think we've any of
you done a press tour like
this before? Yeah. Sort of.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
This is the best one ever.
But you're, you know, you're in a
city, a different city every day,
sometimes two cities in a day.
And you realize when a rock star comes
out in a city like this and says,
uh, you know, thank you, Cleveland,
you get Y if they may have misspoke,
because if you lose all sense.
MMM.
But yeah, it's, it's the,
the, the thing with us,
I'm all over the place here,
but the thing was as usual,
the thing with us is we had
this deep and meaningful,
full goodbye at the end and it was,
you know,
it was pretty heart wrenching
and emotional and then
we realized how ludicrous
it was because we spend so much
time together is this movie was,
uh,
it was one of the greatest joys of my
life and I think collectively hours to,
to get to portray this band and for me,
this man is everything to me now,
but the relationship that we got out
of it is, is just a special to me.
That's awesome. All right, cool. We're
going to take some ice questions. Um,
first of all,
these must be really long days for
you is you're promoting the movie.
So thank you for coming in.
Thank you.
I'm imagining the audition process
must've been kind of weird or different
because it's so physical and there's
the musical element to it. Um,
was it just a normal
addition where you just like,
I'm kind of curious like what the process
was like given all the things that
they would require of you
for making this movie?
It was slightly different for
all of us. I see. I mean, uh, I,
I a different way into it, but I was, I
was expecting to have like a guitar test.
That's the least. Right. That's
the least I should expect.
So light you for weeks leading up to what?
While all this was like in the,
in the balance,
I was just madly practicing guitar and I
paid for us some lessons just on my own
with a teacher and prepared myself
for a test that never came. Yeah.
MMM.
And then all of a sudden you
find yourself in a rehearsal
room going, okay, right.
Just get to work. So it was,
I think maybe, I don't know why
they didn't do that, but maybe they,
because we had hand doubles
on set everyday. So I think
maybe they thought, well,
if he can play it, great, if you can't,
we'll find a way around that. Um,
I didn't want him to get the right
actors for the park for anything,
but thankfully you've got to the end of
the shoot and never used those handles.
So, uh, there's quite a,
it became a point of pride for all
of us are real and we felt a sense of
achievement at the end of it.
When these poor guys who'd been on set
every day easiest job in the entire,
uh, didn't have to bring Brian
Mason know. Um, yeah, for me,
uh, I, I met the producers at one point,
they asked me if I could play guitar and
I was just like a not as good as queen.
And they were like, oh, okay. And then I
was like, well, that's not happening. Uh,
I sort of moved on with my life,
but then like a month later I got a call
saying that like, you know, try this.
I think you really look like
John Deacon the bassist.
So I googled him and I was like,
oh no,
I have to ask my mom
some serious questions.
Were you in England in 1983? Yeah,
I mean just looks so much like me.
And so I the same thing.
I immediately like went to one of my
best friends was like gimme your Bass
Guitar. And I tried to learn how
to play a couple of the songs. Um,
but then all they wanted me to do,
they just,
they just showed me this interview
with John Deacon. They said, hey,
can you just like show us your
accent, English accent. Um,
and it's just like a little interview we
did where he's like riding around in a
bus. So I just looked at
it on my phone that day.
I just went out and drove around a parking
lot and kind of match the light of it
and just like while I was driving,
so I just took a selfie video
of me like doing the interview,
like into like the phone and then just
watch and I'm just like, I should,
I was pretty good. I'm going to send
that and I just like send it off to them.
And then before I knew what they were
like, we don't need anything else.
And it still took like a,
for like two months before I found out
I got the job queen was actually playing
in Brooklyn where I was living in.
I was like,
should I go to the concert and like hold
up a sign says put me in your movie.
And then the next day I
found out I got the job.
So it was one of those sort of fun,
fun way.
And it's bunk as how much you look like
in like one of the first times we all
were in costume and makeup was to do a
photo shoot to the props needed to make
up a version of the greatest
hits with our faces on it
and sound like we all
turn up to me with a wig.
You with the mustache and a wig
band with a wig. Joe just turned up
like this is pretty much maybe how a
shave well, yeah. And it's like, Oh,
it's John Deacon. Yeah. And um, they did
give me a perm. That was fun. Oh yeah.
I'm glad they did. That for me.
Really helped me get into character.
I still to wear six wigs.
He didn't realize it.
Prune was abbreviation for permanent.
I did not
send it 10 days. It's just kind of washes
out. They're like, oh no, six months.
I just like clown hair.
I loved it whenever we want.
Whenever we went out,
Joe would always have this,
the Yankees hat is new Yankees hat and
then like he'd be like chatting to a girl
or something, you know, a bar. And
then I just take off the hot guy.
True Story. So now you know his
character. I'm a good friend.
Loud wingman. But good friends.
Sorry, one more time for one more.
All right.
So obviously the relationship between
the members of the band was very core to
their creative process.
How did you develop and convey that
relationship between your characters on
screen?
We were lucky that we've
got to ad Lib so much. Um,
that was definitely one of the things.
Um,
basically every time we showed up on set,
we were just making up half the lines.
I mean,
I think the majority of my lines in the
movie are things that I just said on the
day.
Um,
and so that is kind of a thing where you
start riffing off of each other and you
know, your character. So we'll, you
know how to react to each other.
And that was part of the [inaudible]
and the editor did a really good job of
just picking candid moments in this. We
didn't even realize it was on camera then
us laughing. I mean, when you see
people, uh, laughter in a movie,
it sometimes feels forced.
You can never predict chemistry.
And in film amaze people,
two people can get along so well in life
and you don't know how it's going to
play in front of a camera.
Uh,
evolve between us was just
so purely genuine bent.
If you wanted to laugh,
you could really,
really sustain it and enjoy it because
it was so real that you never felt,
oh, this is, this is too
much. This feels canned. Uh,
everything was just so natural with us.
Uh,
since it's such a rare thing to
have and we had the freedom of,
because we got to know each other
and trusted each other so much,
we could ad Lib with one another.
And we knew where to pick
up and start so many.
There is not one scene in this movie
that probably doesn't have at least
something that was thrown in
on the day from one of us.
It was great having Mike
Myers, uh, all of her scenes,
we were quite close to the
beginning of our shoot.
And so having a master like that set the
Preston but like throughout the shoot
would be like,
I'm not going like,
do I need to just try and
emulate is kind of naughtiness.
There's cheekiness and a lot of the things
that he used to say to himself on set
became catch phrases to us.
Like before I see any gun just
for cheeses is it gives us,
that would be his way. And just that
playfulness was like, okay, that's,
that's good. That's all we
need to do. That's incredible.
All right,
cool.
We have to wrap up and I would be remiss
to leave this question out if we could
just go down the row and, uh, your
favorite queens sites. I'll, sorry,
I want to break free. Really
rarely. Why do you like that one?
So that's such a cool rhythm. The baseline
is so fun. The precaution is just like,
it's Kinda got this bumpiness to it. It's
fun. I Dunno. Cool. We're of time. Thanks.
Score one for John Green. Turn
your chairs this way, but please,
I love under
pressure. Uh, I'm a massive
Bowie fan as well. Uh,
you know, they, they happen,
I think what works so well with
Queen and especially Freddy,
just love when things weren't planned
and they ran into Bowie one day in the
same city and same recording
studio. And he said, hey,
why don't we do something today? And, uh,
they began putting
something together and uh,
what did John Do? You came
up with some, some, uh, yeah,
yeah, I forgot it. And money forgot it.
They went and had a slice
of pizza and came back
and, uh, he couldn't remember if
the baseline, and then Roger goes,
no, when something like this on the
drums. And that was the evolution of that.
And then, uh, but we started writing
something down, went into record it.
And Freddy went to listen because
he was so competitive. He's like,
whatever he's doing, I'm
going to do something. And uh,
he just went and you hear that,
you hear him hitting that,
some of the highest notes, uh,
he's probably ever hit in that.
Then you get to here is operatic
warmup, you know, the DDA,
all of that is in there. That's just
special. All the stories you get. Um,
you know,
the,
the of the making of these songs and
doing the research and in the film is what
I find the most special about their music.
When he got
somebody to love us. My all time
favorite, I feel like, you know,
Bohemian Rhapsody's obviously
their masterpiece, you know,
but I feel like somebody,
it'll, it was equally so, um,
and it's a little more accessible and
it just like the lyrics kind of speak to
you, you know, a bit
more. Um, so that was,
that's that one's always been my all time
favorite. Then like some deep tracks.
I like, like father to son and action
this day I've been singing all day today.
I always love exactly
the same songs as Joe.
So it's allowed me behaving rhapsody,
but this film now has given me like an
emotional connection to every song when
we play there and make songs that,
you know, so radio guard got,
when I have heard a recording of that,
I'm like, yes, this is a good song,
good song. When I hear it
live aid and like, oh my God,
it's incredible because that was the
moment when you just go Freddy's onto
something here like this there. This
is a special moment cause it's when he,
when he really captures the crowd and
you just see that engagement with 70,000
people and you kind of like,
I mean what's great with this film,
we saw it in a screen yesterday,
huge screen in Dallas with amazing sound
system and you have like the vibration
of the music going through your chest.
Like you're at a concert and it's
that kind of like epic feel that,
that I love about that song performed
on that day in July and not, you know,
you're five. That's awesome. Cool.
Thank you guys so much for
the phone is incredibly, you
guys nailed it. Um, and I'm
so glad to have you here.
Uh, thank you guys so much.
If phone comes out in November 2nd so
if you didn't get to see it last night,
even if you did go back and say it again
[inaudible].